l'entrée des établissements scolaires
les voitures des films dits parents
déposent leurs enfants au compte gouttes
comme d'habitude et bien sûr ils sont
interpellés par la vive controverse a
provoqué par la mode - qui prévoit de
remplacer les mentions pères et mères
sur les formulaires scolaire par parent
est pas rendu il ya un pea il ya de
meilleur dans une famille baud p1
belle-mère et peut-être mes parents un
parent du nom alors après c'est quoi par
an 3 par an 4 dans les familles
recomposées on fait comment fille et
parents inquiets par an de non il faut
arrêter un moment pour concevoir un
enfant il faut une femme un homme un
père une mère et après c'est toute
pensée bon comme mon combat pas aussi un
parent ben ammar a jugé ici risque est
prioritaire qui sera pas prioritaire
pour moi dans ce sens et ce moment - je
vois mes parents soient toujours un
parent est aujourd'hui parents parents
de sam interrégions la destination de la
société vous êtes pour cette mesure de
parents un parent 2 pour le sociologue
louis zunino le remplacement de père et
mère par parent 1 il part en deux est
une vraie fausse bonne idée
l'humanité au genre et en mettant des
numéros à la place c'est la première
chose ensuite ça dépend de ce qu'on veut
mettre de ce que l'on jeudi assure
parent est pas rendue si c'est pour dire
que et qu'on fait la corrélation avec la
neutralité avec les questions du genre
ça devient problématique parce qu'à
l'école pouvoir donner des informations
privées s'ils ont déjà mis sur le mode
de vie des parents la bonne chose
ensuite la deuxième chose c'est qu'on
dira qu' un parent et homosexuels
viennent qu'une femme biais qu'elle n'a
mis qu'un différend mollissez les mecs
quand même pas rendue je voudrais pas
que ce soit une bonne chose pour la
société puisque à terme on risque
d'arriver dans nos sociétés où en fait
on catalogue on enregistre des
informations sur les gens et on je
dirais même qu'on les fics face à la
levée de boucliers provoquée par cet
amendement le gouvernement a changé son
fusil d'épaulé en proposant désormais
que soit l'outil dans chaque case perry
mr laissons le soin finale aux parents